[Music]
20:18 is here and incredibly enough the
Earth's core hasn't melted down yet as
of this taping somehow humanity has
managed to survive several
extinction-level events over the past
couple weeks including but not limited
to the Republican tax bill passing net
neutrality being repealed Russian BOTS
trolling Twitter and of course
late-night trump tweets while it's
pretty clear that the endless hysteria
about the return of the Nazis the
hyperbole describing the end of the
world and the general lunacy of our
collective social media hive mind is
going to continue into 2018 and beyond I
want to take a quick look back and make
a prediction for the year to come
in my first direct message of 2017 I had
said that if 2016 was the year of fake
outrage then 2017 would be the year of
misguided anger though I'm not
Nostradamus I think my prediction came
out looking pretty damn good my
prediction was based on a couple trends
but primarily that if you spent all of
2016 saying that Trump was Hitler and he
turned out not to be Hitler that you
would have painted yourself into an
intellectual corner which could only
come out in misguided anger once you've
labeled someone as Hitler you really
can't walk your statement back by
acknowledging that they might
occasionally do something good this line
of thinking was a trap that the left set
for itself and is one of the reasons I
spent so much time in 2016
trying to reform the left the endless
name-calling and virtue signaling was
obviously gonna lead to more misguided
anger if the prophecy of Trump as Hitler
didn't actually come true after all you
can never give a hitler figure credit if
he does something good so you just have
to endlessly double down and slide
further and further to the extreme you
may hate Trump's appointees the
Republican tax plan and more but you do
have to face that Hitler he is not to
continue this line of thinking is to
dishonor the millions of people who died
at the hands of a fanatical madman the
misguided anger which Trump's election
brought didn't just affect politicians
and pundits but ordinary people too and
day I get dozens of emails from regular
folks who are losing friends who are
ostracized by their family members or
most dangerously just afraid to say what
they think because it may fall outside
the accepted narrative news
organizations from BuzzFeed to
Huffington Post to CNN and sadly to even
the New York Times have exposed
themselves as places of leftist activism
more than places of honest and unbiased
journalism while the 2016 election
should have brought some introspection
among this class it instead brought a
doubling down of attacking anyone who
steps outside of the accepted norms this
dishonesty and desire to control what
you think is exactly what led to the
rise of the trolls the meme makers and
those pesky frogs okay on to 2018 while
there clearly will be no course
correction by those who trade and
identity politics and collectivism I see
many signs that their movement is
beginning to lose steam of course if you
were tracking this all along you knew
this was the inevitability of the
oppression Olympics if you believed
victimhood to be virtue then you must
always be a bigger victim than the
person next to you this is the fatal
flaw of intersectionality together you
aren't stronger you are actually weaker
because of your competing interests this
is why leftism collectivism socialism or
whatever you want to call it has always
led to more authoritarian control and
more dead bodies in the name of
Tolerance
it's a snake that eats its tail and
right now if you look close enough that
snake is about halfway through with
lunch while the snake eats itself those
of us who are woke as the kids say are
gonna find allies every which way we
look right before Christmas I spoke at
the largest gathering of conservative
college students ever at turning-point
USA's annual conference in Palm Springs
many former Rubin Report guests were
there including Ben Shapiro Dennis
Prager and Greg Gutfeld
during my speech I talked about being
for gay marriage for a woman's right to
choose and a slew of other so-called
liberal ideas the speech wasn't just
warmly received I actually got a
standing ovation for talking about our
differences and how we can find common
ground
I'd be happy to do the exact same speech
for a progressive organization but I
won't hold my breath waiting for the
invitation while one side preaches
tolerance but doesn't actually practice
it
I think 2018 is finally gonna be the
year that this script gets torn up and
rewritten
if you truly stand for the individual
and believe that we should live in a
free society where our differences
should be relished and not relinquished
then you will find people to connect
with in every direction just look at
some of the diverse voices who we had on
this very show who caught fire in 2017
like jordan peterson brett weinstein
lindsey sheppard Laci green Colin
Moriarty and Yasmin Muhammad these
people came from all across the physical
map as well as the ideological map yet
have found common cause in fighting for
their ability to say and think what they
believe
so if 2016 was the year of fake outrage
and 2017 was the year of misguided anger
I believe that 2018 will be the year of
unusual alliances if you make the
decision in your mind to be for the only
diversity that matters the diversity of
thought you will quickly find it easy to
find friends where you once found
enemies and as has happened to me on
more than one occasion sometimes in this
very studio you might just change your
mind instead of changing someone else's
it can be humbling and even scary when
that happens but that's the risk of real
diversity and I think it's one well
worth taking my challenge to you is to
do something this year don't just talk
about it do it whatever that is to you
start fighting for your beliefs in the
real world not just by using hashtags on
Twitter even if you disagree with me on
every single issue out there get out
there and fight for whatever it is you
believe obviously don't use violence or
your right to free speech to infringe on
someone else's right to free speech but
stand up for the ideas that you care
about the old system of politics media
Hollywood and even sports are crumbling
right before our eyes and it's up to us
to decide what will come next
I believe that we have a chance to build
on the ideas of classical liberalism of
libertarianism of individualism and of
personal freedom instead of
authoritarianism socialism leftism and
more authoritarian control I will fight
for these ideas like never before in
2018 and I hope that you will join me
whatever that means to you
[Music]